most people enjoy a good western but
there are probably a good few of them
who have thought
you know what this western needs some
supernatural demons
well wynonna earp has you covered from
the source material to its dedicated fan
base
here's the untold truth of wynonna earp
when show runner emily andras read the
winona irf comics for the first time
she knew that she had to bring wynonna
to life on screen
she told the mary sue when i picked up
the comic i really got all tingly i was
really like
oh my god if i could just cook something
up for myself in a magic cauldron
this is everything i would pick she
pitched her idea to comic book publisher
idw
who loved andrus idea especially when
she described it as
quote if buffy meets justified meets
frozen
as a writer and consulting producer on
the space drama killjoys and a
showrunner on the supernatural drama
lost girl
andrus could easily translate winona
earp from the page to the screen
wynona irp story began back in 1996 when
writer bo smith
published the very first comic featuring
the character but when smith began
working on the comics he received
pushback from nearly everyone involved
with the process
he wanted wynonna to come across as
mature confident
and powerful but the publisher and
artist he was working with wanted him to
take things in a different direction as
smith admitted in an interview with
uproxx my battle 20 years ago with
winona erp was a hard one
i battled with not only the publisher
but with the artist to not make her a
stripper with a badge
that was the way everyone wanted to
portray her because that was the thing
going on at the time
that was something i fought andrus
definitely changed up winona's image for
the show and gave her some more modest
costumes
but the spirit of smith's original
character definitely comes through
in melanie's grow thanos portrayal of
wynonna
while emily andrus lifted many of the
characters in wynonna earp
straight from the original comics she
also brought some new faces to the
series
for instance wynonna's sister waverly
doesn't exist in the source material
and neither does her girlfriend and
local sheriff nicole hot
both become fan favorites especially
when they began dating
now bo smith has incorporated both
waverly and
nicole into the comic series and he's
interested in finding a place for more
tv characters in his work
as he told uprocks it's always been a
point for me to bring as many of the
cast members
and even some of the one-episode
characters into the comic as possible
he continued on about his goal to make
the comics more seamless for fans who
only knew of the show but he made sure
not to leave out his original readers
either
saying for the core audience that has
been around for 20 years
i want to give them something new in
addition to certain characters from the
tv series missing from the pages of
earlier comic issues
the narrative isn't quite the same after
all it kicks off with winona's return to
her tiny home of purgatory
and while fighting supernatural forces
is certainly a major focus of the series
many of the episodes also center around
the relationships and interactions
between the characters
you're hardly qualified to give
relationship advice remember that guy
with the satanic face tattoo
what phil really loved norwegian death
metal but in the comic book series
wynonna sets off on an epic
action-packed road trip across america
it wasn't until he'd already published
several issues that smith sent wynonna
to tombstone arizona where wyatt erp
famously fought in the shootout
at the o.k corral of course the comics
that have been published
since the show began airing have clearly
tied in with the series
so today fans would probably spot more
similarities
melanie scrofano has earned
well-deserved praise for playing wynonna
tim roseanne is a natural as doc
holliday and as waverly dominique
provost chocoly really seems like she
could beast growfano's little sister
so fans might be surprised to hear that
at least one actress on the show
auditioned for several roles before
finding the perfect fit
catherine burrell knew that she wanted
to be part of the series but it took a
couple of auditions until she landed a
role
as she explained in an interview with
sci-fi vision they did kind of a wide
net casting call for winona and i
auditioned for wynonna and then
like a month later i auditioned for
waverly and then maybe a month and a
half
later i auditioned for nicole now
barrell is captivating as purgatory's
sheriff
and her chemistry with provost chocoly
is undeniable
wynonna irp fans will be happy to find
out that several of the cast members
have connected outside of the show
catherine burrell and tamera duarte
actually worked together on another film
that was released shortly before wynonna
earp began airing the 2015 rom-com
my ex-axe which was about a woman trying
to decide between getting back together
with the man who recently broke up with
her or reuniting with her college
boyfriend
additionally greg brick who plays jack
of knives is the father of billy brick
who plays billy clanton greg began
acting in 1998
and in 2018 billy followed in his
father's footsteps when he landed his
first professional acting job on the
series jet
alongside his brother dempsey brick
wyatt earp lived in the american west
but wynonna earp is actually set in
canada wynonna's hometown purgatory is
located near the canadian rockies
as andrus who grew up in canada
explained in an interview with sci-fi
bulletin
it was a chance to get back there and do
a show that takes place not in the
claustrophobia of a spaceship or in an
urban landscape we could bring all these
demons running around the mountains
and the plains and the badlands it felt
really fresh to me
the idea of a supernatural western the
series is shot at various locations
around calgary alberta and the town of
didsbury stands in for purgatory on the
screen
after watching a few episodes eagle-eyed
winona earp fans began noticing a
curious pattern
all of the episode titles seemed
recognizable and the phrases
sounded especially familiar to country
music fans for instance
in june 2017 an episode titled gonna get
you good
aired and a fan reached out to andrus on
twitter to ask if the title
was a reference to the popular shania
twain tune i'm gonna getcha good
andrus responded yep all wynonna earp
episodes are named after country and
western songs
this choice is an homage to the western
roots of the story and once you notice
it looking up the episode titles becomes
a fun trivia exercise
some of the titles are easy to place
like the season 1 episode i walk the
line while the episode whiskey lullaby
gets its title from the modern country
hit of the same name by alison cross
and brad paisley when wynonna's
pregnancy was revealed at the end of
season two
fans were shocked originally the writers
hadn't planned for a pregnancy storyline
but when scrofano found out that she was
pregnant in real life
she knew that she had to tell showrunner
emily andrus
we need a plan and we need it fast cause
this sucker's coming out my vagina
yeah my vagina jeremy however she didn't
think that they would be able to
incorporate her pregnancy into the
series
instead she assumed that she was going
to get fired or that the show would be
cancelled
as she told the tv junkies i just
started projecting that they were going
to take the show away and be mad at me
and i got really angry
thankfully scrofano couldn't have gotten
a more positive response from the team
behind the show
saying i told them and they were so
supportive emily right away
started having ideas and her brain went
into how can we use this for the story
the season was even extended by two
episodes specifically to focus on
wynonna's pregnancy
devoted wynonna earp fans were
devastated when they found out that the
show was on the chopping block after
they'd already been promised future
seasons
this one's quite a kick in the box yes
man
idw publishing the company that owns the
rights to the winona earp comics and tv
series was on the hook for hefty
production costs
and they weren't sure if the expense
would be justified so the fans decided
to mobilize
they raised funds to put up hashtag
fight for winona billboards in new york
and los angeles to prove that future
seasons would have a dedicated audience
as bonnie farrar a copywriter who
manages a highly popular winona earp fan
account
on twitter told the hollywood reporter
we want networks to know that this
fandom is loud
and mighty and passionate we will
support all of the networks and
companies that continue to produce
winona earp
we are all in as a fandom and we are
loyal the response from
enthusiastic fans clearly had a positive
influence and the fourth season began
airing in july 2020. it was a huge
victory but sadly
it was short-lived as the show was once
again cancelled in february 2021
when the show began airing wynonna erp
fans started connecting on social media
and if you happen to scroll through
twitter when a new episode premieres
you'll notice that this fandom is highly
active and super welcoming
andrus and the cast have praised the
fandom for creating such an
uplifting community around the show and
avoiding the negative behavior that
often plagues these virtual groups
but no matter how sweet her fans are
melanie's growfano makes it a point to
stay away from social media when she's
shooting new episodes
explaining in an interview with vulture
you have to balance what people would
like to see and what is honest to the
people who created it
that's why i get off twitter when we
shoot because it's like
wow i am being very influenced basically
scrofano wants to make sure that her
performance
isn't influenced by comments from fans
on social media
even positive comments beau smith wants
fans of the winona earp tv series to
feel like they can see a whole new side
of their favorite show by reading the
comics
but he also wants to give them some of
the familiar material that got them
hooked on the show in the first place
and what better way to do that than by
inviting a few of the actors themselves
to contribute to the comics
smith collaborated with melanie scrofano
and tim rosan to put together a special
collected volume of the series titled
wynonna earp
legends scrofano and rosanne each worked
with smith on different issues
and both actors found the experience to
be very rewarding with scrofano telling
entertainment weekly
as an actor you tend to just look at the
script till you get to your stuff
but then when you're writing it just
really makes you go what does this do
for them
it deepens your appreciation for all the
characters which in turn just makes you
appreciate the whole of the story that
you're telling more
it makes you less selfish in theory the
death of deputy marshall dolls came as a
major shock to fans
dolls who helped to protect wynonna and
her family was a beloved character and
his feelings for winona ran deep
he was clearly in love with her and he
was willing to do almost anything to
keep her safe
but early in season 3 dolls gave his
life to save wynonna and
fans were devastated to see him go
however the writers didn't choose to
kill him off
simply to make room for new supporting
characters instead
shamir anderson who played dolls had
negotiated his exit well in advance
and had worked with the writers to
figure out his death scene while
anderson loved working on winona earp
he was receiving offers for other
exciting opportunities and he didn't
want to pass them up
however he wanted to make sure that his
death on the show was meaningful
and left a memorable impact as emily
andrus told tv junkies
it was extremely important to shamir
personally that he have dolls go out as
he lived
which is a hero check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]